why you should learn to create a cloud
workstation config enabling developers
to be productive in their own
workstations is a labor of love time and
Care goes into documenting what
libraries and utilities to install and
what Ides to use to actually help them
get things done and even then if all
goes well with their setup you're still
left with worrying about other things
like having them pull in store company
code locally or managing bastions just
so they can access VPC scope resources
now there has to be a happy medium right
where developers can have what they need
to be productive while working in a
safer environment that's where Cloud
workstations comes in you can use cloud
workstation configurations to Define
what your developers workstations look
like down to what Ides will run on them
all while being able to manage access to
these VPC scope workstations via IAM so
if you're looking to secure your
developers work environments while still
prioritizing their productivity check
out the tutorial Linked In the pinned
comment where you'll see for yourself